leute ich hatte einfach mal wieder work
spontan für ein video welt zu fliegen
und habe mir die frage gestellt wie
günstig kann ein flug eigentlich sein
ich habe mich ein bisschen im internet
schlau gemacht habe ein paar wege
miteinander verglichen und habe diese
eine verbindung gefunden für
unglaubliche acht euro 99 leute hier
kann man wahrscheinlich nochmal sehen
wir fliegen jetzt one way für neun euro
99 nach italien und das ganze einfach
schon morgen alles gleich mal wirklich
die gespendeten sachen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
leute was geht ab guten morgen meine
augen so walter wir haben jetzt gleich
nur ich bin schon etwas länger wach und
in der halben stunde muss ich meine
wahrnehmen richtung köln bonn flughafen
weil wir um 11 45 oder so oder 11.30
geht der flug das lustige ist weil so
günstig war konnte ich auch noch ein
freund vom überzeugen mit zu kommen also
ich würde sagen ich wünsche euch ganz
ganz viel spaß bei den block und ich bin
also ich konnte mich doch klar wenn ihr
die idee geil findet lassen nach oben da
und wir machen uns jetzt auf den weg
[Musik]
leute das blöde ist ich kann leider nur
einen rucksack mitnehmen weil ich pflege
mit ryanair und die haben irgendwie ne
party mal auf jeden fall habe ich eine
mail bekommen dass das handgepäck nur
noch so aussehen darf deswegen kann ich
auch nicht viel mitnehmen das ist noch
ein bisschen programm auftragen das ist
ja gut riechen
also sachen soweit gepackt dann machen
wir's mal schnell auf den weg zu wahren
sollte das wetter in köln ist leider gar
nicht geil aber deswegen klingt sind
sonnige italien gerade regnet es zwar
nicht mehr aber was auf jeden fall heute
noch ich habe halt mal nachgeguckt wir
haben in italien 21 grad
also höchst einem traktor für recht
angemeldet und sonne auf sylt angekommen
am bahnhof jetzt muss ich erstmals zu
frühstücken holen und das passt doch in
meinen anderen block den ich gerade noch
parallel aufnehmen ist eigentlich ganz
lustig
aha die bahn hat schon wieder verspätung
soweit
luca
und ich finde
märz 11 uhr erst um 12 uhr geht der
flieger also genau einer stunde hätte
man hier von meinen kollegen finden
das soll sich schon da der anfang
sie sind am falschen terminal wir müssen
da hinten
so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wir haben
diese uhrzeit hier für neun euro 99
wegfliegt da ist das uns ja wir fliegen
übrigens mit ryanair
also hier regnet und ich hoffe in
italien scheint die sonne auch ihr wisst
doch gar nicht wo es hingeht das beraten
[Musik]
leute ganz kurze wundert euch nicht
warum ich anders aussehe ich bin jetzt
schon im flieger zurück haben den wir
auch sehr spontan gebucht haben weil wir
noch einen freund in stuttgart besuchen
jetzt übers wochenende und ich habe
wirklich überhaupt keine ahnung warum
das ist aber auch der flug zurück
den haben wir für acht euro bekommen und
das ist irgendwie glaube ich gerade wir
haben einfach glück mit der zeit und der
flughafen bologna oder zumindest die
connections der nachbarn hier sind halt
mit so billigflügen wie wir sind jetzt
gerade mal machen sehr sehr sehr günstig
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt angekommen hier in
italien wir sind in bologna ich weiß
nicht ob ihr das kind ist schon eine
relativ große stadt und ich habe mir
jetzt spontan noch ein hotel gebucht das
ist relativ in der stadt da haben wir es
erstmal hin und also ungefähr fünf
kilometer von hier also gar nicht mal so
weit flughafen das ganz neues aber ich
weiß nicht können bestimmt mal kurz
kaufen hier oder vielleicht kann man die
auch für einen tag mieten
[Musik]
total in die taxifahrer die beachten
gegen wieso auch
verkehrs leben verstehen wir jetzt nicht
was ist diese nachricht von freunden
kann so also dieses hotel habe ich
spontan gebucht jetzt gucken wir mal wie
das zimmer aussieht wie sieht eigentlich
ganz nett aus hier hier 211 soweit also
wir sind jetzt hier in unserem hotel
kollegen nach oben weil er jetzt bei
sonderkunden auf jeden fall habe ich das
hotel hier wie schon gesagt auch spontan
dazu gebucht das weite als zu teuer und
das ist auf jeden fall ganz cool hier
vom hier die betten den fernseher und
hier ist das bad an das licht ist glaube
ich nach ist ja auch egal
die aussagen ganz normal ins hotelzimmer
und wir schauen uns jetzt erst mal um
die dachterrasse um so einen überblick
zu kriegen von der stadt hier wo wir
eigentlich gelandet sind weil ich war ja
vorher nie ich habe auch noch nie von
jemand gehört dass hier schon mal war
deswegen habe ich bin gespannt leute wir
sind jetzt hier auf der dachterrasse
hier kann man so ein bisschen den
ausblick genießen auf ja ich glaube da
vorne ist irgendwie die stadt hier sieht
aber ganz cool aus hier gibt's sogar
sein whirlpool
mal gucken wie die stadt finden und hier
kann man auch noch ein bisschen seine
körperform also wir suchen jetzt mal
eine busverbindung um in die stadt zu
kommen um uns herum sind halt überall
ihr wohngebäude also wir sind schon ein
bisschen außerhalb aber ist ja gar nicht
so schlimm muss kostet auch noch 150
eine ewigkeit später
ich habe ja gerade noch gesagt dass der
bus so günstig so günstig ist und jetzt
sind wir uns im bus gesprungen weil er
noch schnell kam und wollten dann halt
ein ticket dort drin kaufmann das geht
auch nur drin geht aber nur mit coins
werten erscheine dabei und diese
kontrolleure die haben überhaupt kein
englisch verstanden und die meinten
jetzt wir sind schwarz gefahren
da gibt es nichts zu diskutieren und wir
haben jetzt hier ein ticket über 90 euro
also das hängt ja super an hier ist war
schon teurer als hotel zwei orange
selbst bestellen weil wir mit
wechselgeld brauchen somit nicht was
kriegen weil es kommt vielleicht ist er
dazu gar
ist ok
zum gefüllt hier hat auch nur zwei euro
gekostet
korrekte die parte englisch
ich fühle mich wie als hätten wir so
1560 also hier sieht auf jeden fall
alles sehr alt aus deshalb
wahrscheinlich so eine stadt wie rom in
rom ist auch so also sieht auch so aus
einen schönen stellen leute jetzt regnet
es einfach halten wir auch anders
vorbehalten so leute wären wir schon
abends hier draußen ist es dunkel und
wer geht da würde ich noch in die stadt
mal wenn wir schon mal hier sind ich
habe allerdings gedacht dass ich die
kamera ist nicht mitnehmen wenn ich noch
irgendwie was cooles machen ist im handy
kurz auf und zeige ich das noch
allerdings wollte ich noch mal kurz
zusammenfassend sagen der schlug hierhin
hat ja wirklich acht euro gekostet und
wir fliegen morgen auch weiter nach
stuttgart und das wirklich ich kann es
euch hier gerne einbinden
auch für sieben oder acht euro stopp
auch acht euro und dann kommen wir hier
an das hotel war jetzt auch nicht
wirklich teuer also ich meine das ist
ein vernünftiges hotel und dann steigen
wir in den scheiß bus und müssen 90 euro
strafe zahlen wenn das halt durch und
ich werde dagegen auf jeden fall machen
weil er gibt nämlich einfach keinen sinn
wir gehen zum schaffner sagen ja wir
würden gerne geld wechseln oder kann
können sie uns ein ticket geben dann
checkt er erstens gar nichts und sagte
sofort ja wir sind jetzt schwarz
gefahren und gibt unseren ticket über 90
euro und ist dabei auch noch wirklich
und freundlich also ich meine ja gemerkt
dass wir absolut keinen plan hatten was
wir hier gerade machen wir sind jetzt
drin
so werden die falsche richtung gefahren
einfach weil wir so ein idol warnt na ja
also wir sehen uns morgen brüdern und
ich hoffe dass hier im wahrsten lustiges
die gefahr ich also auf jeden fall ein
sehr ereignisreicher tag kann man so
verzeichnen so das letzte mal die schöne
aussicht genießen fenster schließen und
wieder zurück leute guten morgen hier
aus bologna
dann waren jetzt eine nacht und liegen
jetzt in stuttgart die leute jetzt immer
wieder im flugzeug
und jetzt geht nach stuttgart war auf
jeden fall ganz nett hier
es geht uns gut mal gucken ob wir hier
für acht euro eine bessere landung
kriegen als gestern
das war nicht schlecht deutschland muss
man immer klatschen so leute angekommen
und stuttgart hier ist einfach viel grad
in italien ist ein sommer bisher keine
rund werke dabei so leute wie sie jetzt
angekommen in stuttgart muss ich einfach
mal vorstellen
wir sind jetzt für 17 euro nach italien
und wieder nach deutschland finde ich
schon etwas in kanada wie findest du die
so leute ich bin jetzt hier in stuttgart
bei christian ich weiß nicht vielleicht
kennt ihr das noch von früher wenn man
erst einmal videos gedreht
auf jeden fall gibt es noch ein paar
sachen die ich noch sagen wollte zu
wenig und nicht ganze kommen weil sie
mal irgendwas dazwischen kommt ist also
bologna an sich ist eine ganz schöne
stadt gewesen
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob man unbedingt
dahin muss so also es gibt auf jeden
fall auch noch schönere städte also es
gibt auf jeden fall schönere städte die
also meiner meinung nach gibt es auf
jeden fall schönere städte die
vielleicht am meer liegen oder wo
einfluss durchfließt oder so habe ich
jetzt auch kein fluss gesehen oder
schlaf war nicht so schön aber was ich
wirklich krass finde ich meine das waren
1000 kilometer flug 1000 100 kilometer
und man zahlt einfach für diesen flug
hin 999 und zurück 8 eur 960 ich habe
fast also selten mal so einen günstigen
flug gesehen und ich habe noch nie so
ein bisschen flug dann auch mal gebucht
und an sich sind das ja jetzt keine
flugzeuge wo kein komfort gegeben ist
oder so an sich sind die flugzeuge ja
ganz normal du bist halt nur kein essen
an bord
guten appetit und dann stelle ich mir so
die frage wenn man sich hier in einem
zug setzt und 20 kilometer fährt kostet
das ja schon das doppelte von diesem
flug und ob das jetzt so sind es für die
umwelt mag ich ja zu bezweifeln deswegen
fliege ich normalerweise auch er dann
mit flugzeugen an
100 eure zeit pro flug oder 200 komplett
auf an
vielleicht ist das ja kein unterschied
nein war schluss soll es ja ja ich weiß
genau aber du musst ja nicht die
billigflieger unterstützen oder weil
sonst gibt es in einigen jahren nur noch
rein und sagen wie viel lauter mal
wieder das argument oder 30 jahren
mundtot gemacht leute das war's mit dem
video wenn ihr sagt macht das doch bitte
noch mal irgendeine andere stadt für
videos mache ich das sonst halt nicht
lassen doch nach oben da waren so
gefallen hat und schon bei unserem
vorbei sein